knowing the standard widget library is
nice but as someone who was once accused
is not so much recreating the wheel as
hand machining minor nuts and bolts I
know there are times when nothing in the
tool chest will quite do the job that's
when it's time to dive in and build your
own custom view from scratch now we're
not going to be including any custom
views within sunshine but we can still
take a look at how you would build one
we'll start by creating a new class for
our view let's call it my view if you're
building something from scratch rather
than modifying an existing view it
should descend from either view itself
or from surface view view offers a
lightweight canvas based approach while
surface view is designed specifically to
support UI elements that require rapid
redraws and/or 3d graphics using
something like OpenGL it's perfect for
views that display video or games now
the existing widget library is entirely
view based so let's take that approach
the base view class draws an empty
borderless 100 by 100 pixel box to
change that we override the onmeasure
handler which allows us to indicate the
view size we'll also override on draw in
order to draw our own custom view
content now if it turns out that your
view should always be an empty 100 pixel
box then you're in luck otherwise we
need to do some work so let's start by
setting our view size onmeasure is
called when your views parent is laying
out its children as you know when you
add a view to a layout you can specify a
specific height or width but in most
cases you'll want to either match parent
or wrap the content what've use on
measure is called by its parent layout
it asks how much space will you use and
passes in how much space is available
and whether the view will be given
exactly that much space or at most that
much space using these parameters you
can decode those parameters like this
and that'll allow you to obtain the size
and the mode for your height and width
specifications in this example we're
demonstrating it just for the height
parameter but it works the same for
width we can then use the decoded mode
parameter to find out what size we
should set our view to if the returned
mode is exactly if you will be placed
into an area of exactly that size you'll
be passed that value of the layout house
fight a specific size or if the view has
been asked to fill the parent in either
case it's best practice to simply return
the value passed in unless that value is
below your views minimum size in which
case you can return the minimum value
and rely on the parent layout to crop or
scroll as necessary another alternative
is at most this indicates that your view
can define its own size up to the size
given this is typically the case for
view set to wrap content where the view
should be as wide as it needs to be to
display its content but no wider than
that and of course all abouts provided
that it still fits within the parent
container as indicated by the size
parameter now we've just finished
calculating all of that for the high
parameter and you'd need to do exactly
the same thing again for width and once
you've done that and determined the size
of your control have to call the set
measure dimension method here you pass
in your width and height values if you
don't call the set measure dimension
method your app will crash as soon as
your view is laid out